there are many myths about consulting
one example of things i
frequently hear is that often in
consulting projects
the result is already decided at the
beginning of the project
meaning the consultants just write down
the things that the management of the
client is warning them to write down
anyway
is all of this true these are the things
that i'm going to discuss
in this video today i'm reviewing the
three most common myths
that i frequently heard about consulting
so welcome to another video here on my
channel
firm learning today it's quite warm here
in munich so i'm not drinking a coffee
but just the water
hope that's fine for you as well as you
know my name is heinrich and on my
channel i want to help you
to become successful in the first years
of your career but now without further
ado let's
jump into the three myths and let's have
a look whether these are actually true
or not
so let's start with myth number one
about consulting and this is likely the
thing that i hear most
frequently when people talk badly about
consultants
and this is that consultants just write
down what other people on the client
side
tell them to write down anyway so pretty
much implying that the results of the
project
are already clear are already defined
from the beginning of the project
and consultants are just there to make
it look good
just to provide justification for maybe
some harsh
measures that the management wants to
take anyway and what these people mean
is that sometimes
there is senior management maybe of a
client this senior management wants to
do some harsh measures with the
organization
often this will be related to cost
cutting maybe even deciding to let go of
employees of people in the organization
and they don't want to do that on
themselves
they just ask consultants to come in and
just to do a project to investigate
these things
and then in the end just to write down
what they wanted to do in the first
place so what is
my view on that and in general
personally i consider this perspective
to be flawed
i never experienced a situation where at
the beginning of a project it was
clear what the result was supposed to be
i never was in a meeting with a partner
or any other senior personnel of a
consulting firm
telling the team explaining to the team
that this is now the task
this is what we need to write on piece
of paper this is what the client wants
of course that being said sometimes you
find yourself in a situation
where the client already has a couple of
hypothesis that the client shares with
you so for instance yes it might be that
the client is looking into cost cutting
measures
and is asking you as a consultant to
evaluate these cost-cutting measures
and then of course depending on the
agreed scope the result of that might be
that the new as a consultant also
proposed things
but in my perspective this is something
very different
than just writing down what the client
tells you in the beginning
of course you're going to pick up some
ideas that the clients has
of course you will evaluate them
potentially also incorporate them in
your final suggestion
though what is important to understand
is that if a consulting firm delivers a
recommendation to the client and this is
of course especially true for mbb
consulting firms
like mckinsey bcg or bain the reputation
of your firm will be very much attached
to the quality of these recommendations
just as an example i
in the past worked for a client for a
firm
and several years ago they apparently
did a project with boston consulting
group with bcg
and bcg developed a strategy for this
client
and this document was still being
circulated through the organization so
this bcg strategy document
and everyone just called the document
yeah the bcg document the bcg strategy
so clearly your name your reputation
is often very directly tied to the
results of your work
and clearly big consulting firms just
would not be able to justify to
themselves
just to potentially damage their
reputation do
things write things down that they do
not believe are true that they do not
believe our recommendation only because
any client is asking them
to do that this is just not how it works
let's talk about the second consulting
myth and this is that consulting is
nothing else than glorified temp
work this would mean that as a
consultant you are not
really developing new concepts and
strategies as an independent party
but you are in the end nothing else and
just an extension of the workforce for
the employer for your client so maybe if
a client needs some
extra capacity some extra things that
need to get done
but the client does not have enough
capacity to get this done in-house
this will be then the scenario where the
client is asking for consultants
just to take them on as temporary
workers to do the things that they
cannot currently do in their home
organization
and my perspective on this is that while
there might be some truth to that
let me come to that in a moment what
that would be i would argue that this is
largely completely exaggerated and not
really the case as a consultant the norm
is specially talking about
mbb consulting firms for mckinsey bcg
and bain
you pride yourself of delivering an
independent opinion
of delivering your analysis your view on
the perspective that you bring to the
client indeed in a normal consulting
setup you are not
directly reporting to the client in the
sense that the client will tell you what
you have to do
of course the client will want to review
your work will discuss
this work with you but usually this will
not take the form of the client exactly
telling you what the individual steps
are
that they want you to complete and for
sure again this is custom myth number
one
they will not tell you what the results
of your work are supposed to be so in
general i disagree with this myth and
this was even something that was also
top of mind of many partners i used to
work with
that they always used to say so what we
don't want to do
is just to be the extended workbench of
the client so just to
get some work done get tasks done that
at the moment the client cannot complete
it should always be a part of your
independent opinion
your perspective that you bring to the
table so that being said i think there
are two perspectives on this
where maybe you could come to the
conclusion that yes there might be some
truth to that
and the first is that the things that i
talked about are very much true for mbb
consulting
but might be less true for other
consulting firms maybe especially
smaller or boutique consulting firms so
while i don't want to say that this is
usually the case there might be some
consulting firms
where your work often is indeed rather
compared to temp work
than to actually providing an
independent opinion and the second
perspective of this is that sometimes
especially in projects
that already ongoing for long time
projects that got extension after
extension after extension
often you are really coming with a
client into really a working mode and
operational mode
where you do tasks agree on next steps
agree on to do's
so these are the situations where then
sometimes the lines get a little bit
blurry
and here also the client just might like
to work with you in this setting
because even though your fees probably
are not really economical
to just use you as a normal employee
equivalent
for them maybe they just don't have the
budget approval not the means not to
hire new people
and it might just be easier for the
client to continue working with you as a
consultant
even though your fees are much higher
than what they would pay to an employee
just out of the convenience aspect of it
so let's look at
myth number three and this is that
consultants actually don't care about
their clients
they just want to make as much money as
possible they just want to collect their
consulting
fees their per diems from the clients
and whether what they do then is
creating any actual value at all they
don't even care about that as long as
they get
paid and i find this way of talking
about this quite
bitter to be honest so surely consulting
firms as
every other firm is a business after all
and will need to think economically
but that this just means that
consultants don't care about their
clients and customers
this just seems very wrong to me and
just to illustrate that so
at my former employer one of the highest
values kind of the highest evolution
level of being a consultant
is really to become a trusted advisor to
the clients to the
senior management to the people that you
work with so whenever one of these
people would have
a problem a business related issue they
wanted to discuss
ideally they would think about you top
of their mind
about a person that they can sit down
with just use you as a sparing partner
discuss some topics with you
and then potentially also then start a
project to address certain issues
so surely deeply caring about your
clients
deeply being concerned about what really
creates
value at your clients and has a positive
impact this
from my experience from what i have seen
was always at the core
of every successful partner i worked
with i'm
not even once experienced a situation
where
a partner or any other senior person of
the consulting firm
would just barely imply anything like oh
this project probably will not go away
but i don't care because i will make
lots of money so that's fine
like not even once in six years working
consulting ever heard
anything like this and again it's of
course difficult now to speak
for every single consulting firm out
there of course
my experiences are very much influenced
by the firm that i worked for
but you know i would assume that at
least for the mbb firms mckinsey bcg
bain
this will be the trend this is the
situation
that you will face and this was also
very well reflected in the culture and
also the whole incentive system so you
were also evaluated even as a junior
consultant
so you would always be rewarded if you
were able to come up with good ideas
that really
helped the client if you came up with
something that really
resonated had a positive impact that
really satisfied the client
made an impact these were the things
that would make you be perceived
as a strong consultant as a rock star
and frankly if you set up your work in a
way that you don't care about your
client success
but just about your own success i think
this will be
very very difficult because often it's
just the truth
these two are very closely interlinked
so the one regularly leads to the other
and the other way around
which i think great because this just
means that the incentives are aligned
so what do you think about these big
myths about consulting do you think they
are true
what are your reflections on that would
love to hear your perspective
in the video comments to know whether
you agree with what i've said or not
as always if you took any value out of
this video at all please hit the like
button for the youtube algorithm
and also subscribe to my channel to stay
up to date on all my content
i'm also active on other channels such
as instagram ticktalk or twitch
you find the links to these channels in
the video description of course as
always also big thanks to all the
members of firm learning
you're really making a great
contribution to the course thank you for
that
my name is heine from from learning was
a pleasure doing this video for you
see you again next week good weekend to
all of you and bye bye